well I'm appalled and sickened that  people should lose their lives in this  way and I thought sir very much with the  the families and friends of the of the  victims today I've obviously talked to  the Chief Constable of Thames Valley  Police thanked him and his officers for  their bravery in tackling the the  suspect we now have someone in in  custody the policeman's get on with  their their job get to the bottom of  exactly what happened and so it'd be  difficult really to comment in detail  except to say this that if there are  lessons that we need to learn about how  we handle such cases how we handle the  events leading up to such cases then we  will learn those lessons and we will not  hesitate to take action when necessary